[Musica]
benvenuti a ricordare che si anita
vitale in casa nuovo video conteremo gli
scherzi di 123 gowan frigo è il canale
youtube rifaremo vai scherzetti super
divertenti l'ha già da un bel mi piace
se volete vedere altri scherzi su questo
canale se questo video raggiunge i 30
mila mi piace faremo una seconda parte
davvero altri scherzi e io faccio scarse
tenuto per sé non mi stai vite ancora su
instagram andate a seguirmi il nome
anita stories se volete andate a
seguirmi anche sui tic toc e ora
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
perché alla fine dovrete iscriversi nei
commenti quale è stato lo scherzo più
divertente secondo voi fronti trento e
orate primo scherzo
avete visto vitale sta dormendo fuori
nella straio in giardino ora io ti
porterò questa prima me la farò bere un
po così non so spetterà a niente per poi
rifare un bello scherzetto
e se vi state chiedendo ma come fai a
sapere se lui lo accetterà
e la barra a vitale posso dare qualsiasi
cosa da bere e da mangiare e la ferrai
mangerà sempre
[Musica]
ragazzi ho preso la pepsi e clicca la
salsa di soia però ho paura che vitale
si insospettiva e se ne accorgerà che
non può vedere il colore attraverso la
lattina quindi mi è venuta un'idea la
metterò in un bicchiere annuzzi in due
bicchieri in un bicchiere metto la pepsi
normale invece nell'altro bicchiere
metto un po di pepsi chiamate sincera
falsati foglia
[Musica]
spero di non comporre i bicchieri
questo è quello che spetta a vitale
specie questo è il mio ma ora torniamo
fuori e andiamo fare lo scherzetto
vitale perché salato aspettavo dolce
prima scherzetti rischi secondo scherzo
ho deciso di dedicarmi con anita per lo
scherzetto di priva e quindi le fare uno
scherzetto io che cosa farò con questo
scotch landro a scocciare alla sdraio la
leggerò alla sdraio con lo scotch
sostanzialmente
[Musica]
bocciata e berlino altro giro impegnato
a controllare le prigioni non abbiamo
visto quanto è di massimo giannini
[Musica]
il via libera bravo berrino libera
arriverà a nozze sono anche le mie anno
[Musica]
iii scherzo che i ragazzi siamo in
cucina per quest'altra scherzetto di 123
gol invece nella panna userò la maionese
non so come far avvicinare vitale al
piatto potrei dirgli che si è qualcosa
da mangiare e dentro ma deve riuscire a
vederla bene per mangiarla e poi splash
gli spiazzi col piatto in faccia
speriamo che ci caschi anche in questo
ma per gli scherzi con il cibo è molto
falsi le gomitate
ora vado a portare inviata vitale
speriamo che circa
[Musica]
io sempre fame assolutamente si aspetta
però non puoi guardare me è una
a non guardare una crema devo prima
spiegarti come come è stato realizzato
questo piatto cucinato turno
cosa vuoi dire tu sei per qualcosa di
nascosto in questo piatto è una cosa che
si mangia con gli occhi devi guardare
molto bene forse con gli occhi che senza
mangiare con gli occhi e guardare molto
bene dentro e se riesce a vederlo lo
puoi viaggiare
ok guarda un po guarda bene avvicinati
bene guarda maionese detto di aver
trovato questa prima fetta perché il mio
padre ucciso e mangiato la foglia mentre
con la pazza almeno mi aiuti a pulirla
[Musica]
[Risate]
quarto scherzo e questa volta che cosa
farò e andrò a fare questo trucco
tutorial trucco ma prima sostituirò la
crema con il bie briciole nell'ict della
colla è che ho detto
questi sostituirò la crema con la colla
sarà insomma 50 unità viene
prego si accomodi si segga qui facciamo
un trucco non sei contento finalmente
tuo fidanzato ti fa un trucco
non mi fido molto e proprio qui
sperimentare in quasi allora io lo
conosco bene tutto tutti i termini della
terminologia dei trucchi chiudi gli
occhi per la chiesa e la sorpresa a
sorpresa quindi gli occhi allora per
prima cosa chiudi gli occhi ha detto va
bene però i minuti per prima cosa fa
questi sono questi eccomi fatto
indovinare sono quattro per prima cosa
dobbiamo idratare il viso quindi
mettiamo una crema idratante strano che
con un gesto fatto che prima bisogna
mettere la crema idratante e addirittura
questa è una cosa molto comune la cosa
della crema idratante non lo sapevo e
allora perché me lo stai mettendo se non
lo sapeva perché troviamo bene che l ha
una tale imposteranno questa crema e
perché una crema di nuovissima
generazione ma che si celi questa
particolare praticamente c'è il retinolo
il secchi tello il retino secchiello
anzi e domani è comprata al nel bazar
che vendevano farmacia questo vendono in
farmacia si è che cosa hai chiesto
quando lei comprata da questa parte per
favore una crema idratante mente
idratante e basta e loro ti hanno dato
che tra l'altro guarda e famosissima tra
l'altro aiuta proprio tanto la pelle
respirare e tutto è come si chiama si
chiama
crema ad altissima efficienza questo è
il nome della crema si no qual è il nome
della marca dalla marca o come boe che
non me lo ricordo miglia guardia nella
scatola nella scatola non solo la
scatola qui adesso entra qualche domanda
e silenzio
sto facendo io il tutorial trucco allora
dopo che idratate bene bene dappertutto
non gli è sapere il nome della crema
abbiamo anti age professional retinol al
bar borotalco e crema pasticcera di
importanti trattare la pelle perché una
pelle idratata e una pelle bella quando
ti interessano così tanto che forma un
formale tutorial su youtube
adesso invece andiamo a mettere il copri
pelle infatti il copri pelle quell'unica
c'è il colore della pelle però il
fondotinta il fondotinta propri pelle
parlare bene come questa credo è perché
è una crema speciale dai sbrigati
aspetto io direi che sono pratico fare
queste cose ci si mette su spendevano un
truccatore alle prime armi
professionista per ora è ormai sono
bravissimo a fare queste cose un ottimo
lavoro per il momento adesso dobbiamo
mettere il colore a guance che cos'è il
colore awards telescopi a parlare con
questa crema è un attimo un attimo
adesso deve fare effetto
e con un ago lancerà praticamente
indovinata che a cosa serve serve a
colorare le guance fantastico colora
guancia applicato adesso l'ultimo tocco
provare anch'io devo aprire gli occhi e
chiude ultimo tocco arma ma ti muovere
labbra bene non credo
questo non lo so come si vede sono
un'artista tesi bellissima è finito
credo che lui ti sia puoi aprire gli
occhi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma sicuramente resisterà l'acqua
sicuramente non segue set
sì è vero ti lamentare del parlato e
fatto una maschera filotto
[Musica]
poi uscirà la maschera della mia faccia
con i verso questo rossetto bello ios
perché tu non abbia preso le mie
sopracciglia no per niente
cappelli venisse soddisfatta di come sia
truccato
no ora veramente in faccia così si
aspetta aspetta molto
sì forse è rimasto incastrato ufficio
bello non ne sono sicuro però che almeno
mi abbia tolto i tuttineri
ecco la mia faccia sembra una casa
dell'orrore
il lato positivo però almeno non ti devi
stoccate nei rossetti mazzini quando
dico io scappo ciao merlino è di nuovo
berlino non li vediamo dai dolci castro
non ho parole che cazzo di ebook ha
fatto tantissimo incollato anche i
capelli tra l'altro è stato un bel mi
piace se volete la mia vendetta contro
vita alla vendetta contro i 30 mila mi
piace faremo dei nuovi scherzi o
testeremo dei nuovi scherzi del canale
123 gol file minuscola sconsigliate su
di voi nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo a casa il link di
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione